[Music]
six years of searching
please let this be it whoa
focus eyes forward took
good boy okay so here's the stitch
this is kumandra each land is named
after a part of the dragon
fang heart spine tail
and talon we were once unified
harmoniously as one
until evil forces were awakened
shattering the peace and dividing the
five lands
mariah this isn't the world i want you
to live in
to restore peace i must find the last
[Music]
dragon
we need you to defeat the evil with the
last of dragon magic i'm gonna be real
with you all right
i'm not like the the best dragon
okay we need to keep going see the
world's broken
world warriors assassins
and pickpockets
[Music]
you can't trust anyone maybe it's broken
because you don't trust anyone we really
need your help
my girl ryan and i are gonna fix the
world yes i too wish to join this
fellowship with particularly
hold on oh we were doing a jumpy thing
sorry it may
feel impossible but sometimes you just
have to take the first step
i just shape change dragons can do that
look how close my butt is to my head
it's going to make digestion so much
faster
or ordered on disney plus with premier
access
[Music]
bye